what's going on reject nation we're back
at it to watch the boys
season two episode seven thanks so much
for being here subscribe and click that
notification bell to get notified
when our reaction for the boys finale is
up that'll probably be
uh divided into two videos because you
know it's the finale so got to cover a
little bit
more i want to say special thank you to
everyone
who has followed us over at our patreon
page and showing your support to the
real rejects over there obviously can't
show the whole
episode here on the channel so full
length reaction watch alongs where you
sync up with the timecode
over at our patreon page we cover so
many tv shows over there like
supernatural
doctor who we just started up avatar the
last airbender
and so much more you can tell by all
these crazy looking thumbnails
i'm flashing on screen don't you want to
join the fun
yeah last but not least special thanks
to eric over at
nerd crotic for editing this video for
us
he's edited for movie trivia shmo down a
whole bunch of reactors like iman snow
akasan i don't know who else
some other people but he's great love
you eric
punch additional punchline
to invade americans pouring into this
country
every day and any one of them could be a
super terrorist super villain
it's an extremist we're going to see an
extremist have a good day hon
but why does it matter what some super
villain loving snowflake happens
every minute this show is so irrelevant
in every way oh there's not america
right now man
he's gonna kill that what is this guy
gonna do he's gonna kill that guy
though he's because he thought he saw
something
oh no he's totally gonna kill him
i saw the light in your eyes what are
you bulletproof [ __ ] please i
have a family please
oh
[Music]
ah frosted atratz
do you remember that
cross that you gave me for confirmation
i would touch it
like a football player leaving the
locker room
the bad guys don't get punished what we
do means nothing
it's just all for money in
america
[Music]
you and me let's let's get away from all
of this get away from thought
escape for a while i cleared it already
what store what you called them yeah
about an hour ago why
mom they could be looking
oh
howie that black noir yeah oh damn
damn chip you guys want to watch deep
does it in the blowhole
i don't want to watch that blessing
you'll love it
is that officially through vaught
translucent the invisible cop
oh my god we made pleasure slave
big black noir big black duo starlight
pulls an atrium
starlight pulls an a straight buddy must
have made that joke at some point in my
life
now look at me you're watching i'm like
the cuck
and the porn sitting on the sidelines
while the real heroes are they're doing
the [ __ ]
well let's go it's a good analogy you
want to know why they left me to babysit
you
because you're useless oh
snap i think he had a more profound
answer in mind
you're not the [ __ ]
i'm the cuck actually you're worse
we're all the cuck you're the cuck
fluffer
oh thanks man
appreciate you one nation under god
remember right before these godless
inhuman supervillains started pouring
across our borders
yeah we need more compound v
absolutely
[Applause]
we also had a mole in the seven
that's right one of our own starlight
oh damn and she can't hurt anyone else
oh no oh my gosh
that was a great fakeout
and i'm sorry man but she's probably
dead well there's got to be something
right like it's like it's okay
maybe one or two but forget it man it's
crazy hey show me come with me look at
you you're still [ __ ] oh get
your friend butcher isn't picking up and
the others are halfway across the state
we gotta go
now oh team cuck
[Applause]
he's gonna get killed for sure and then
there goes their witness
let's go [ __ ] the wife consensually come
on come on
don't hate me but your dad's alive he's
alive isn't it yep
knew it you called it i'm just jumping
on that oh my goodness
i knew it might be i'll push you a bit
odd
i looked at ya you're going to be afraid
of anything
oh you're welcome so what is this
conversation you wanted to have exactly
i know you're the one who abandoned him
no mate
this is why the mom butcher here please
just do it
he could never have done that christ
billy so much better than lanny billy
oh no no no
no what oh she wants a baby
oh she does want a baby
no he's not going to show her his son
he's going to do it
oh no
no two seconds before it happened
great call [ __ ] hey guys oh no this is
so uncomfortable
there's a storm front storm front this
is rebecca
no you are the
first natural born oh no
[Music]
[Applause]
hi here's their five minute scene for
this episode let's go
hey they're our favorite characters yes
and everyone in the comments knows this
she is not a monster
[Laughter]
i lie awake every night thinking about
that me too but then i start snowballing
and wondering
how many other people have you killed
and what else have you done i have a
choice
not blaming you i'm not i just need
time sheesh
this is the real me
domestically violent i was gonna say
i just threw my food
i don't like the real you nave's best
scene all season right there people
we both know vaught [ __ ] you probably
put you in that chair
testify to congress don't be a cuck
i'm sorry to say this grace but you're
the very last person who should be
asking me for help
do what you like to me but some things
are more important than the right thing
i need to dissect that let's put this on
pause and really
really break down deep dive
i'd like to hear about your family keep
them alive a bit longer
so just overcome that speech thing
gun i'm seeing gun
yeah well obviously
what what else would this be
this is shotgun this is assault rifle
frenchie is flew into a sign language
gun
what do you guys think of uh eagle the
archer oh he's like a brother to me
eagle the archer's coming back
he's a toxic personality and no church
members are to have
oh god whatsoever jesus right
claims the program had failed him but
actually
he failed the program
[Music]
checks out i've heard this many times
many many people
who turn their back on scientology
[Laughter]
she will be back in your arms and you
will be totally fine
you're america's second favorite lesbian
couple after all who's the first
what do you think ellen and ellen's wife
for once in your life be a [ __ ] human
being
i'm really sorry me
she looks like she could be emma stone's
cousin yeah
vape nation compound
vape what is this when you look at him
you think of me
how you
[Laughter]
wow oh did you make this himself
that oh no hey flywell
dances
[Laughter]
i do not want my son to have to go
through what i went through he has to go
to vaught land
i didn't know what to do the first time
i went to fartland
but what's best for him is to be here
with me with his mother
look we have this opportunity i'm so
afraid he's going to just snap
him begging you please
[Laughter]
the name's william butcher
[Music]
[Laughter]
that's got to be a shot from the comics
or something
my family would be your family's already
in trouble
cause i'm about to go into that room
next door to your door
and i'm gonna bash your brains out your
whole
[ __ ] family dice today
he is sexy huh he's pretty sexy
how how can can you be
suck how can you be such a monster man
i've never known anything of the like
you're a doe
i'm a killer
moved my statue what
i wanted to do it in front of my statue
not he was going to kill himself
oh
you are terrible babysitter huey
light
cool shot
[ __ ] you man you just ruined everything
huey though
like oh and i need his hand
would they still be able to recognize
his hand i don't
think so come on come on
why does it look tasty she has no idea
what the tv has been saying about her
black noir versus starlight
cool she's just going to take his other
hand
because she's definitely still out of
the system
[Music]
wow
come on black noir you're better than
this
that can't be as painful as the pillar
that's going to be expensive to fix
she's caught again it's the end of the
season
maeve you're doing stuff babe
i hate asking i'm asking
he has a tree nut allergy oh
i'm so conflicted oh
he's my favorite seven member no
but she gotta do something heroic
i did not expect that
hell yeah maeve i'm proud of you yuri
oh man
hey she was excited damn mom what are
you doing here
luke skywalker came to rescue
okay let's let's let's keep going you
ready for dinner
oh oh no oh it's going to be worse oh no
you're a liar oh no you lied to me what
do you mean he just blew me up and
showed me
that his house is making the neighbors
are making your fake
boy deserves to know the truth
yeesh yeah i know that you must feel
confused and there are reasons for this
don't touch me i hate you
i think he just needs a little space no
all right he needs his mother don't
worry
he'll still have a [ __ ]
oh my god the chair calls former cso of
vaught
dr jonah vogelbaum
do you swear that the testimony you're
about to give today will be the truth
the whole truth and nothing but the
truth i do that's a major opening
[Music]
it's cindy cindy
really it's in line with her abilities
whoa damn oh my god
don't kill ashley
jesus oh grace
oh my god
you guys cut really really bad
oh wow what an ending guys
what more to say thanks for being here
we'll see you guys soon
you said cindy and that has to be your
powers someone mentioned it in the
comments last week they were like come
on that could be cindy and i was like oh
what do you mean last week what do you
mean
when we on our review someone was like
you guys the head
exploding thing could be cindy oh
because of the first person that uh
whatever her name was
character from season one yes from the
cia yeah
oh yeah
[Music]
then again it could be some other
head-popping thing that we just haven't
seen yet
but it would make more sense again cindy
especially since we focused on her we
just saw
her powers and it was very similar so
they could be wanting to tease that
man that was a cool ending you think
it's just one head and then when
everyone's head starts exploding
all right two key witnesses
dead this this episode they really know
how to
rip it out of you man first lamplighter
which we got to talk about and then
you're like oh okay oh they got they got
one
they got the duck and then bam yeah they
got better than lennon
yeah that's better than stronger i know
i was like damn
i didn't even say nothing man and then
butcher just being pushed toward the
edge and then when you finally think
he's achieved something where he could
be a little bit happy
to just end on that last shot of him of
up i [ __ ]
had it with these boys he's lying right
there he's seen in his face
yeah you really do oh that was great
fantastic stuff
i liked this episode a hell of a lot i
loved it i felt like the theme of it
was parenting if you look at all the
main story lines you got a homelander
and storm front going in there parenting
number one
starlight and mom and then there's a
third one butcher
butcher and his parents yeah even huey
relates a story about his own parents
two lamplighters yeah that's what i mean
and the church of convert the
convergence place
that guy is like apparent to them all
exactly but let's
the first three are really the main
tie-ins of the parent thing right yeah
so which parent one uh
babe you decide which parent one should
we start with first
storm front and homeland good because
that is definitely the most interesting
one
yes that was an unexpected turn of
events
it was like horrifying and heartbreaking
all at the same time
i love the way that that unfolded
because at first you're like okay
becca's maybe appealing to some kind of
humanity left within homelander and then
yeah they just come right back around
with him and stormfront usurping her
entirely and so it seems like she's not
safe anymore
you know especially if they sway ryan
that much further away from her favor
i mean this is a better option
than killing her though right
they're still not gonna do that but yeah
yeah i'm like if this
if things continue in this fashion and
if ryan really drives that wedge in and
doesn't want to see his mom anymore i
could definitely see her being you know
in the crosshairs
but where are they exactly becca and
ryan where have they been staying
because
it sounds like they're in some weird
sound yeah they're in the compound the
butcher broke into
yeah so this does she know how to get
out of there herself she doesn't know
how to leave herself i would assume they
don't want her there anymore
they're gonna be like bye [ __ ] who
gives a [ __ ] about you i don't know but
they're her favorite that's
their favorite resident yeah they've
done so much to maintain
i don't know i guess it would depend on
what if any reaction
fought themselves have because you know
vaughn must be in control of yeah this
compound and keeping them
so you know we'll see but still man like
they they toyed with the whole thing
with stormfront
going in there in the most brilliant of
ways when they're at that rally
and then she sees the baby first thought
is aw crap she gonna want to have one
herself right now that was my first
thought
and then this is even worse i kind of
forgot about ryan
like this is worse but then then the
thing comes did she already know about
ryan
she seems to already know everything
about vat who's stormfront
yeah yeah she said that she knew
everything about ryan too ryan
no but she said homelander told her but
did she know about him beforehand
so is her ultimate goal to get to ryan
the pure soup
or just gain another level of leverage
over homeland or via ryan because if she
endears herself to him
like i don't know how season this
season's gonna
end but i think it would be pretty cool
if they set it up in a way where ryan
is like the main threat of season three
and cause time jump and he's jensen
actually yeah
they could work maybe there's this thing
about this
kid that just seems such like a tortured
youth man
everything with homelander and then now
to turn on his mom in this way
and he's got the super powers and all
that rage within him
you just know that man look at him go
you guys can't see what we're seeing
right now but we got we got a cat right
there who's just who's learning who's a
velociraptor he will meet out throughout
this whole video and that's okay well he
just has such like
a tortured soul and it it seems like as
i was kind of wondering why we've been
focusing so much on butcher's backstory
you know there's a version of this where
it could feel like it can undercut a
character because
a big part of him is like he's so
mysterious and then you're diving into
the mystery of his backstory so you're
kind of taking away some of that mystery
when you're really explaining
full-heartedly
why he is the way he is i've been
enjoying it though
and i think the reason we're setting all
this up
is because now obviously becca's gonna
have to go
to butcher for help and he's gonna be oh
i don't wanna be like monday
or something [ __ ] that he says and i
don't know how that makes him not like
his dad but it's probably a different
choice of what his dad would do
so you would that's what makes him not
like his dad i
solved it
but him having to go help out becca
would be a thing where he would be
going down a different path and his dad
and having that ending conversation with
his mom i really have been liking all
the exploration with his character that
we've been getting slowly
from his aunt and then his puppy
and then now his mom and dad it's been
great man
it's been great yeah and i like the
nuances of that story i mean just yeah
especially having his mom have to
lure them into talking to each other
with some sort of ruse and doing it as a
thing for him to let go of more than a
thing to you know validate his dad's
life or anything like
yeah it is nice to kind of peer beyond
butcher and then
also to watch the contrast of hardness
when he goes and talks to the doctor and
he's like i'm going to kill you the
whole entire family
and that was another one about parenting
okay so when you had that scene man even
before that when he's going full
rage mode on his dad i couldn't think of
another moment in this show this chara
this character has so much rage within
him but that was the most i've seen carl
urban go just full-on with his eyes
and the way he taunted the doctor in
that particular scene
oh god enjoying that
teen just as much as humanly possible
there's a great scene
okay next one lamplighter lamplighter's
power is fire how is he not immune to
his own power
i don't know i mean there's a guy with
acid earlier in last episode but i think
he can control fire
yeah and manipulate it but i think when
he sucks but that's impressive that he
was able to
uh keep the fire on himself the entire
because he could just let go because my
mind was going how did you just catch on
fire
he's wearing clothes still though but
wouldn't you still need some like
gasoline or something
[Music]
well i mean he's got only one way to
prove it guys he's got
he's got his powers so he's just like
hey flame
you know oh wow so you can just catch on
fire with just your clothes
yes of course sure clothes are flammable
did you know that cloth burns
wow and water is wet
let's prove it to you flat earth
but we didn't get to have a fight i'm
keeping all that in the video
i edit the review part guys and i'm
keeping the part where greg looks like a
dumbass in the video
it's all good sorry i've never set
clothes on fire i
don't know i don't know basic things
i've immolated myself this is all new
skin grafting in the last couple of
years here looking isn't this
great i know the word skin grafting but
i don't know that clothes catch on fire
no by looking at it what i liked about
how that went down
it seemed like it was gonna go down the
path that you were saying you know the
most generic pathway would have gone
where
oh man witness been killed because he
was trying to be a hero but this is more
in tune with what the
what we've learned about this character
over the last couple of episodes
and also there's some uh erotic vod
videos out there
that i'm wondering if they ever will get
released online
along with ryan's lego version
of films that are about white saviors
it's pretty decent at those little films
dude just by the clip
style i thought this was a vlog original
earlier this doesn't look like it was
shot on a phone it looks like there's
some focal lengths
that part of your super powers little
man that's his true yeah
it's not the ability to fly or have heat
vision it's just really
great eye for sun you like the bit
it was fine it was fine for a while
and when it went on too long welcome to
the real rejects
i mean hughie seemed to show absolutely
no remorse
i mean what side would you guys be on in
that situation if lamplighter killed
himself would you be just
the way how he was like [ __ ] you would
you would you be that feeling that way
cause he i thought he
don't think he looks at the big picture
he only looks in this tunnel vision of
starlight starlight
and he doesn't look at the overall big
picture of what that would do
to the the case that they were trying to
build against spot he just doesn't look
at it
maybe he was mad though because of the
case or are you saying he wouldn't have
brought him there if he was thinking
about the case
right he wouldn't have pressured
lamplighter to get there
if it wasn't for the kids because he
just has tunnel vision yeah with
starlight's in trouble i mean your love
will do that to you kiwis no
you don't do [ __ ] for me so don't even
that's not true i force you to be here
to watch the boys
this is benefiting you
[Laughter]
you're remember that show we watched
together alone yeah
and now we can put her on youtube
you're welcome i really like the
sequence i i really enjoyed the sequence
of sneaking into vod
i don't get how va there's there's been
some several it's also doesn't make
sense because
his hand print still worked yeah that's
my point is that every episode
even the last episode there were things
i was talking we were talking about my
buddy aaron about wait a minute there's
like logical gap holes and and
i think every one of these episodes has
something where there's kind of a
logical gap hole here
and his handprint going on there i gotta
say is one of them i i feel like they
would have because he's not technically
is he still
part of like vaughn would he still have
access to it that's where i'm i feel
like vaughn wouldn't allow him to
because even he was like
i don't know if i uh there's a
possibility and in my mind with the way
vot
is if there's that possibility it most
likely
it wouldn't work in his favor and they
even took a statue away yeah
i'm i'm torn i guess i'm not as torn on
that as as you guys
it's a big thing it ruined the entire
show john but the only thing i i
the only rebuttal i would give is that
he is technically still working for them
just not
there he's you know this is what the
tight bot is
and how they don't want people to break
in and did he say at the beginning that
that place was
super hero proof and he just okay we're
on the floor
here we go well though the box they keep
them in is super
yeah she got out immediately but there's
a reason
put a hole in the death star so that way
they could blow it up exactly and then
again so did that move
in this system that was the play galen
ursus to thank for
all convenience that's too bad man i
like that i i liked seeing him in this
role i thought he
i thought he was doing a great job so
the bummer for me is like oh man i was
really enjoying his performance a lot
yeah it's funny because i thought to
myself you know i really like seeing him
i
kind of wish that maybe like it seems
like it really fits the tone of the show
for him to do what he did
although i kind of wish yeah there could
have been maybe a little more after
impact with him before he went out
yeah and the thing that kind of saved
that for me was then i was sitting there
going oh
okay so you know we got this other
witness now
so at first you're like well okay i
guess it just doesn't matter and then
when that comes down the pike and that
when this gets taken out too then you're
like oh wow
we're so royally screwed i thought i was
feeling safe now in light of lamplighter
but now i just feel worse
yeah yeah good call good good call
hey thanks guys watson liked it
this is so close he agrees with him i
know i feel i'm hoping he'll get to a
point where he figures it out but the
sequence of seeking into vaught itself i
thought
was really enjoyable like there was a
there was a fun little pulse to it
and uh wait how did starlight break out
what what what
lit up her room to allow her to break
yeah i love the way that was shot all
the framing they did with her
there i was actually appreciative of the
fact that you know huey
broke in there to rescue her but he he
really didn't need to be there
and start like they still got to have
the reunion moment and what mattered was
that
huey was there to save her even though
she was already
saving herself and then maeve
did [ __ ] this was her episode this was
maeve's episode
she's speaking i'm gonna take away her
lesbian girlfriend
that's all you got to do yeah man
make her straight characters
that's the message to the show no we're
joking
obviously she's not she was sleeping
with that guy to try to
turn away from this path but i liked her
scene that she had
with elena showed a lot of good depth
there and then she got a chance to be a
badass
i mean that was conflicting because
black noir
i think we all love him yeah we all love
him he's my favorite member of the seven
he's the least morally possible to pin
down i have no idea if i should hate him
or not
but like that fight was cool him and
starlight going at it started like
he couldn't do [ __ ] man she really
couldn't there was a lot of electricity
here you're in the conference real quick
like there's got to be electricity here
right she didn't do anything but then
when maeve showed up and she got a
chance to do
i thought she was gonna go like full on
superhero but but black noir is not dead
he just had an allergy reaction right
i think yeah he's in bad shape can you
imagine if they killed off black you
are with another from an alvin
and that's hilarious it literally makes
me so upsetting
but also hilarious it makes me wonder
about the product
placement more so with fresco because
i'm like this church is clearly not
supposed to be a good organization
i've heard a lot of the product
placement ones are kind of inside jokes
more than they are product placement
i read something about the fresco and i
forgot what it was but i know there's
something specific
about spoiling the show for yourself
yeah wow yeah with the pride
that's the most spoilery part is the
financial side of the ship
a train is part of the convergence now
but i still feel like he's a little he's
still got his brains
yeah hilarious oh obviously
this episode i really felt in particular
were
taking just lines quotes
from rallies you know which ones
and so much of this from from the rally
scenes to the scientology stuff was was
pulling
things yeah i was like these are mentors
straight up just
quotes i'm hearing now from both sides
here and then
also with uh yeah the the scientology
one i thought that was really funny the
way they handled it
it's it's funny if you you follow
the how the how scientology has handled
people
leaving the church and talking bad about
them like that's
a hundred percent what they always say
man still though
it really feels like it's just gonna be
a setup for season three
it's like a preview for season three
every time we check it's barely in the
show you know what i really like that is
easy to forget about because it was the
very beginning but i i really
liked checking out for a minute in that
intro with this
random guy who's just a normal person
who's being
forgot all about that yeah he's really
taking in all these star
uh stormfront messages and stuff like
that and is really
radicalized yeah it's literally kind of
going to show the effect that this could
have on regular people and like when he
kills that clerk
like that was a pretty chilling scene to
me anyway like especially i love the way
that guy played it
it's like there's a lot of fun stuff
like those lines that come out at the
rally or with the scientology that are
very familiar but there's also stuff
like that that feels
very realistic at least in in with the
superhero stuff yeah move that yeah i
thought was
an interesting way to start the episode
i mean it's a great social commentary
because
of how this show already had that great
setup from the beginning of this series
of what if superheroes were real how
would we monetize them and then now
showing
like just the people just a person of
how would
someone who was on this side of the
fight
how would they start having their mind
become a little bit
warped and be influenced and what
actions would they take and how
poisonous this is
that who's the real hero is lying it's a
very realistic approach to
this crazy fantastical show now let's
talk about the a train porno
um there was a lot of aprons
in this episode even a trans replacement
just got his head blown off so
oh yeah that's right oh my god but was
eddie the eagle there or what's his name
or something they brought him back
so happy to see him back in the show at
least even if he's being denounced but
maybe he'll become a main character
is there a storyline we're missing i
feel like we covered it all is there a
storyline we're missing
did we yeah we did yeah we did i feel
like right
but it but it doesn't look like the
seven are doing it it could be
it could be uh giancarlo esposito who
has helped set this up in some way
could be hey there's a lot of mystery is
he there i didn't see him i didn't see
him there
if it is cindy though at the same point
why i mean she's
a why would she have the agenda to do
that unless somebody is controlling and
how far is her
range to do that yeah is she in a car
somewhere just like
yeah like she's watching them on tv
she's like miles away with a sniper but
just
exploding oh man
it seems like we touched on everything i
mean there were little moments for
frenchie there were little moments for
like mother's milk and grace so cute
the french the frenchy moments oh i
loved his lines and
like that whole scene yeah that one
frenchie scene looked good
these are just beautiful wines
that was a real like natural way he got
there to get her to start opening up too
important storm that's great that was
beautiful i really love this episode a
lot
i love this one i i love the last few
have been
pretty top-notch man i love this one
for next week and every single time man
the freaking stormfront and homelander
are on screen together it is
just gripping and cringy
all at once any little new choice they
make i'm like
no you stop that doesn't make me want to
be why are you doing this
please you could be just right when they
enter the right when they fly onto the
ground of [ __ ] becca's home like oh
god
where will this go this is the worst ah
all right guys well the boys did you
hate this episode
do you want to see um ryan
adapt more why i'd say green
the uh great you gotta do a green book
the help
uh there's a whole bunch of movies that
you can do yeah totally
wait what's terms of endearment about
because if you dance with woes and
blindside cancer right
i don't know just about the exploration
of cancer this cancer is raceless
[Laughter]
it's a cancer that only affects oh
they're all movies about race
dances with wolves is the white guy
cowboy with the indians
and then uh blind side is uh
sandra bullock helping bullock yeah
maybe he's already a little secret
racist
well no he's not he's woke that's why
he's making movies about white saviors
white saviors white saviors and
and women looking for love in terms of
endearments woman looking for love yeah
it follows a hard to please aurora
looking for love and her daughter's
family problem
is there cancer in it um you know there
could be let's go back here
let's read the wikipedia all right guys
well leave your thoughts down below
thank you for being here last but not
least
daniel gallacher i just want to shout
you out because if there's anybody who's
on the edge of developing you know i
know that you work at a pharmacy and
that's all
cool and you know chill and normal but i
know your game man i know what you're up
to
you're up to some kind of scottish
equivalent of compound b to give
yourself
powers it's not adderall it's it's i
want adderall
we're not talking about you or daniel
i'm sorry all right these guys hate you
but i love you
and i just wanted to give you some love
today send me
some of your scottish drugs all right
and if you could just
hard you know i'm doing my best to
concentrate and not
listen to what they're saying while i'm
talking
daniel i love you okay you're my
homelander
and i want to be your storm front so
let's make orion
[Music]
you